[music playing]
This is, like, pretty legit.
That's, like, a long ways.
I'm pretty pleased
you're saying that.
I'm definitely feeling it.
I mean, this is
300 feet at least.
Ultimately we want to
get down into the gorge.
Let's rappel off the bridge?
Yeah that's a great idea.
[music playing]
This is, like, pretty legit.
Ultimately we want to
get down into the gorge.
Free solo climber
Alex Honnold and I
are high up in the Swiss
Alps, trying to get
to the bottom of this ravine.
Let's rappel off the bridge.
That's a great idea.
All right, can we
try and do from here?
Are you sure?
Do we have this much rope?
Yeah.
We're going to need this.
We're going to need the
extra length and also
the emergency length as well.
[music playing]
So what we're going to
do, counterbalanced repel.
You go one side, I go the other.
As long as we go at the same
time it's going to work.
Right and as long as we
have twice as much rope.
This is a technique that
the special forces use a lot
because it's fast and
it doesn't actually
require anything to anchor to.
But we're going to need all
of our rope and the spare rope
to reach the bottom of this one.
This will be about a 300
foot counterbalanced repel.
And by using the same rope,
Alex and I will attempt
to descend simultaneously.
But if one of us puts
weight on the rope
without the counterweight
of the other person,
Alex or I could plummet to
the bottom of this ravine.
So we've got to make sure
we go at the same time
and maintain the same
speed during our descent.
The thing is, what
I do know is there's
going to be a lot of
friction still on these bits.
And that is the sort of
stuff that can cut rope.
So I do want to do
something that protects us.
Any spare socks?
I mean, I guess you
could use my socks.
Grab them, there's
some of in the bag.
You got any spare ones?
Yeah, for tonight.
There's a lot of abrasion
on these wires, little bits
of metal sticking up.
They're just the sort of thing
that would cut through rope
really easily, especially if
we start bouncing on this thing
as we're descending.
So I reckon if we put
over the top of that.
That is a very
improvised rope protector.
I think it's good.
It's going to run through that.
OK, this is the most bomb
repel of my entire life.
This is totally amazing.
OK, here we go.
This feels suspiciously
like jumping out of the plane.
Like, here we go.
OK, so we've got to
go at the same time.
Yep.
All right so,
maybe not too much
at the same time so don't
wreck each other's [bleep]..
You ready?
3, 2, 1, see you.
[music playing]
Should we stay a
little bit apart?
Yeah, like this is good.
[music playing]
So bouncy.
Yeah, that's why I put
the rope protection in here.
[music playing]
OK, we'll get a bit
middle speed now.
OK.
Whoo, see, most
of the time I have
to go super slow with guests.
This is great.
[music playing]
That was a fricking
amazing repel.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
It's a long ways.
That's a pleasure.
That's a lovely
repel, it's super fun.
I think the socks add
some nice padding.
That's how you do it.